denn die lassen
herzlich willkommen hier neuesten platte
alles klar
als ihr werdet verwandt sind und ihr
fehlt ist auch hier schon meine damen
und herren wir haben uns ein bisschen
stellt glücksrad auf deutsch also summa
summarum look zeigen
hier haben wir verschiedene channels
drauf bestehen wie beispielsweise mit
dem finger beim anderen unter die achsel
und tatsächliche oder hier
beispielsweise die gestützt machen oder
was bekomme oder sich küssen küssen ist
tatsächlich das einzige positive von
diesem ganzen challengers auf jeden fall
werden juden nicht nur abwechselnd
dieses glücksrad drehen und das was man
quasi hier oben angezeigt bekommt die
challenge muss man halt machen banks
first
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt fand ich aber alle ecken auf
durchliefen stimmig mannschaft
[Musik]
da dafür gletscher wird allerdings deckt
ist und julia das ganze gemacht hatte 80
ja- und will keinen stopp liebhaberin
sketche die dass sie nun natürlich durch
gestiegen das heißt wenn jemand dass sie
nun bekommen sollte werden einfach
normal und eine andere stelle zu machen
als mao nicht freuen das heißt für mich
als challenge ist liegestützen wie viele
15 dass ich meine hände sind so komisch
aber ich habe blasen an den händen vom
kart fahren und das übel wenn ich noch
mal auf dem boden fast so wie dieser
blasen sie gesagt dass sie sagen dann
beim wasser das insekt 20 jahre nach dem
doppel fest also muss auf die abende da
ist ein juristischer rat beträgen
und julia hat bei inter gefeiert
für mich ist mit einem stuhl reden das
ist so tun das hat sich jude überlegt
die produktion eine mission mit dem
alles klar
ja bei mir auch das heute so gemacht
das würde ich nie machen acht geräte ein
kumpel hat es okay ich dachte jetzt
achten
das ist also bei mir ist es so ich habe
einen übels verenden ja auch normal
füttern mit brot nehmen von brot
klienten durchfall den hab ich gelesen
meine familie meine freunde des rente
also muss sie dann nur der berg laden
habe hunger
ok schauen was ja ich grüße sie ja ich
werde diese vom stuhl hier weil man das
eigentlich auch mal mit fragen machen
wer überlegt weil hier ja wirklich 14 3
felder sondern werden auch so ein
spannender mitgeliefert bekommen wo man
mit womit man das halt einfach im weg ja
vielleicht machen wir sagt ich bin ich
schwer überlegen das ganze mit fragen zu
machen also beispielsweise steht dann
hier drauf ja das ist eine körbchengröße
du gehörst ist eine kette
das schreibt die kommentare wie das
ganze ordner mit fragen machen sollen
vielleicht in der woche oder ist aber
die muss erst mal reden noch mal drehen
[Musik]
2000 jahre später unter die achseln und
ablecken richtig befürchtung wenn er
davon erzählt für mich ich bin das
rating ist am 13
zeig ich euch zum ersten mal die pizza
kapitel luca 15
rewe edeka über deutschland als mal dass
unser ziel akku
das ist einfach stein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
peinliche story dabei habe ich mir
gedacht dass wir das bekommen diese
challenge muss in seiner instagram story
entweder ein feierliches bildhauen oder
sich zu irgendwas kleinlichen bekennen
oder keine ahnung was hätte ich werde
ganz kurz ein es ist nur die gier von
katja richtig cool findet seit 104 mal
angucken wenn ich hatte ja hallo ist
wird nun mit dem mädchen machen dann
kann ich mich auf jeden fall würde ich
mich recht freuen
juli lädt das jetzt gerade hoch markiert
auch noch die karte also leute wenn ihr
dies so wir sehen wollt geht auf juni
account hoffentlich ist da noch online
und die oder hat sie noch nicht gehört
ist schwer und schule das ganze
allerdings was du bist bei direktwahl
und er boden gut
ich hab doch ganz gerne fahren das war
so richtig versucht dich zu irgendwie
ufc nebst allen erwartungen ist liebe
freunde das hatten wir schon sagt wieso
muss mit ihm gemeint
jetzt gab's natürlich länger dauernder
aufwand ist was dran kommt aber noch
nicht hatten uns war kopfhörer auf und
laut wählen
[Musik]
er war
leader
krastel klebestreifen auf arm wieder
seine jule gey leiter walter 2 das ganze
fleisch ist es brennt aber da sind habe
ich lade sie darauf 50 beim anderen
popeln und essen
er war so ist das auch für mich wirklich
alles für dich oder
[Musik]
ich kann für mich einfach nur aber auch
jetzt ja leute schreibt mir die
kommentare ob wir auch schon mal beim
bei eurer freundin gekoppelt habt der
mitmenschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend nase wäscheklammer für den
rest des videos
ja das muss ja für den resten videos
auch bei gesicht haben
das heißt ich das verträgt sich da
passiert wenn ich ja gerade die beste
kamera was junge so viel speicher
zufolge lag die sowieso schon mal haben
ein tor besser geschmeckt
auf meiner zunge sondern mischung aus
brotbelag und make up und leute gab
tatsächlich noch küssen übrig das
einzige positive ist das letzte was wir
waschen bürsten bekomme ich mir jetzt
noch mehr bestraft
[Musik]
das sieht man das nicht anders aus
danach läuft das jetzt guck mal das
roadbook hier ist irgendwie anders
durch das heutige wieder zu alex auch
berg meine damen und herren es euch
gefallen hat das gerne war ein like
dabei trifft nicht ausbleiben werden
jedoch nicht das gleiche doch bald
positiv und negativ challenges machen
oder mit fragen die wir dann beantworten
müssen da könnt ihr uns auch gern gesagt
in die kommentare schreiben
meine zurück wirklich ekelhaft gerade
[Musik]
die meinung